hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and if you're anything like me
you believe that a glass of wine at a
p.m. makes you a better mom the best
part is you don't even have to have kids
to be a wine mom this evening I'm
bringing out something very very special
this was a gift from my mom who is also
a wine mom her mom was also a wine mom
so I come from a long legacy of wine
moms and this is almost like passing the
torch and it says finally a wine glass
that meets my name so technically it's
one glass
here's laundry you tonight I desperately
want a third child but I really don't
want to be pregnant if I didn't have to
be pregnant I would have like five more
kids I already have two boys so like if
the third was another boy I feel like
I'd just kind of drown in the
testosterone it's not the right time
it's not happening for us right now
so let's drink it so that brings us to
tonight's topic the best and worst words
the best worst parts about being
pregnant so buckle up your seat belts
because we're gonna go on a wild [ __ ]
ride and you're a wuss get the [ __ ] out
including you Kevin what your awaz will
start in a positive note we'll start on
a negative note first the pregnancy glow
is a lie I don't know what kind of women
have this like amazing beautiful
experience God I'm so in tune with my
body I feel like a goddess
nothing was beautiful about my
pregnancies I felt like roadkill the
first three months a bloated corpse the
second three months and a beached whale
the third three months no glow but if
you have a wonderful pregnancy I'm very
happy for you but I kind of [ __ ] hate
you enjoy your glow you big [ __ ] next
this next weird ask rainy there are some
pretty weird cravings like I know some
people crave like laundry detergent and
they want to eat it
yeah women create weird [ __ ] when
they're pregnant
I liked the dryer sheets like the ones
that smell like clean linen I just like
wanted to lick them
it was just like get this inside of me I
need it I might have licked the dryer
sheet a couple of times both pregnancies
it's like it feels like one glass of
Warren next free boob job
pregnancy is basically like one giant
free boob job I was a bee before I got
pregnant and then I was a double D
before I gave birth my husband was not
unhappy about this whoo mama's got DS
and as a flat-chested girl that's like
the only time that I've had big boobs it
was like ya know I don't know the other
half lives
I want to go back in time and do a slow
Baywatch run in my double D's on the
beach like just just savor that moment
forever
next unwarranted touching when you have
that like cute baby belly towards the
end of your pregnancy everybody thinks
that suddenly they can touch you so I
cannot go to the post office without
some weird man like coming up and
rubbing my belly and it's always this
prolonged touch with like weird noises
like mm-hmm
and I'm standing there like are you done
can I go I feel like it's slowing me
down a little bit next weird dreams I
don't know if it's the hormones or the
fact that there's like another brain
inside of you but you have the most
vivid dreams during pregnancy and that
can be either good or bad I had one
dream that my husband was cheating on me
and it was so vivid and real that I woke
up very angry the next morning but I
couldn't get over it for like a week
even though he didn't actually do it and
he would be like I didn't cheat on you
why are you mad and I'd be like you
better make this up to me sometimes the
dreams are really graphic vivid awful
scary dreams but then other mornings I'd
wake up having had a sex dream about
Judge Judy and it's just she's very
generous in bad just in case you're
wondering next pregnancy sex I think
this is different for everyone but the
first two trimesters were great it was
awesome I was just like more and my mom
were more my husband was the happiest
guy on the planet there's a third time
Esther I just want you to like with your
partner try having sex with a watermelon
in between you like duct tape it to your
stomach and see how it goes
because that's the third trimester and
get creative and you do a lot of side
actions like laying on the side I
couldn't even deal with like being on my
hands and knees because it was just like
this weight pulling you down that's like
having a dumbbell hanging from your
stomach like you don't want to get on
your hands and knees like that it's not
pretty it's not comfortable it's not
good there's a lot of side work this is
getting gross okay I feel like it
aerates it I don't know what aerating
does but I've heard it's good is it
laughs oh you know what I forgot I
forgot to say shopping for little cool
but in the end the best and worst part
the best and worst part is that if
you're not going to remember I don't
remember [ __ ] from my pregnancies the
only reason I am telling you these
things today is because I wrote them
down in a diary your body
biologically makes you forget and then
you're gonna want to do it all over
again so drink up before you do so
that's all I got for today if you watch
this all the way through call your mom
send her text
tell her you appreciate her because it
sucks being pregnant having babies she
birthed you you ungrateful piece of [ __ ]
and I shouldn't say that
better yet write her a card because we
love that [ __ ] until next time I'm
Hannah your friendly neighborhood wine
mom I'm gonna put some plastic wrap on
this go that I dream of Judge Judy
ah they come in twos oh my baby